each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning that's my pleasure
introduces a canderson he's here
interviewing for a postdoc position he's
in grad school at Berkeley working with
Eric Brewer keeping the world safe from
buggy systems programmers like me thanks
thanks ed I suppose it said I'm here
from the University of California
Berkeley my advisor is Eric Brewer and
today I'm going to talk about compiler
I've been working on for safe and
efficient C programming but first I'd
like to tell you a little bit my mice
about myself I'm early from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania and I stayed there to do an
undergraduate degree in computer science
and after that I moved to Berkeley to
work on a PhD with my adviser Eric
Brewer and I'm interested in compilers
and type systems in static and dynamic
analysis for improving software quality
and safety and also in language features
for aiding concurrent programming and
the application of all these things to
systems programming and I'm also
interested in building and releasing
useful tools so I worked on a bunch of
different things while at Berkeley so
when I started out as a grad student I
initially was working on deputy which
was Jeremy Condon's dissertation work
and I wrote the optimization phase and
improved some support for fly morphism
and some other things
I also worked on heap safe which is
another project in the ivy group which
checks calls to free by way of reference
counting I extended it with some
algorithms for the multi-threaded case
and next I worked on a project called
shark which is my dissertation work in
which I'll talk about in detail in this
talk I've also been working on something
called atomic shelters which is and a
pessimistic implementation of atomic
sections for C which is kind of like
Auto Locker if you know what that is but
it doesn't have it doesn't need whole
program analysis to find a global lock
order I've also been working with the
par lab at Berkeley in the OS group
they're adding a variety of small
features to Ivy to support their
programming and I've also been doing
some more theoretical work with my own a
cat Intel labs Berkeley using data
gathered from concrete runs of a program
to construct an efficient keep
abstraction for use in a subsequent
static analysis so in this talk I'm
going to give a brief overview of the
design and some of the implementation of
the IV compiler for C I'll talk a little
bit about the design rationale and the
safety guarantees that it provides in
particular I'm going to give an in-depth
look at the concurrency checking part of
IV which is called shark and short for
sharing checker I'll give a brief look
also give a bleep brief look about how
it supports a shared pointer base data
structures and finally I'll show some
results from applying shark to about a
million and a half lines of C code so
programming error is a big problem I
probably don't need to talk about this
in detail with this audience so I'll
just go straight through that so the C
programming language is widely used I've
even heard that people who use it here
at Microsoft so people use it because it
affords the part of our a lot of
efficiency control and it's used tried a
bunch of different system software
operating systems database systems web
servers compilers and so forth people
also use it for applications programming
36% of the projects on on SourceForge
use at least a little bit of C so C code
is mostly correct over time over the
past 40 years or so or whatever
programmers have developed a set of
idioms for writing correct C code that
is things like you know keep the length
of the buffer nearby the pointer to the
buffer or protect a global variable with
mutex of things like that but C
compilers don't really check that those
idioms are followed so in in more modern
languages sometimes these idioms are are
strictly enforced whereas in C either
they're simply conventions
but unfortunately you probably can't
take all of the C code there isn't
rewrite it in the modern language and so
part of the goal of the IV compiler is
to develop an evolutionary pathway from
C to a language with more modern
features that is we want to allow
programmers to improve the safety of
their code one module or one copulation
one compilation unit is fine but also
one safety property at a time so we want
to allow the programmer to declare that
the declare the idiom the the C
programming idiom that they're using and
then have our compiler check that
they're actually using that idiom
correctly so we're we're doing this our
current approach is to add type
qualifiers and some other small features
to the language and the reason is that
even C programmers are at least a little
familiar with types so and then we can
do you know a little extra type checking
a little extra static analysis to make
sure that the programmer is doing what
he says he's doing and we can use some
dependent type qualifiers to express
some some richer properties if we need
to so the IV compiler currently has a
few different parts and I mention these
tools before so deputy heap safe and
shark so deputy enforces spatial memory
safety heap safe adds to that what we
call temporal memory safety and I'll say
what I mean by that in a minute and char
gets to add to those tools concurrency
safety and a bunch of a bunch of people
have been working on the ivy project
people from Berkeley and Intel apps
Berkeley yeah so today I'm going to talk
about shark but first I'll give a brief
overview of the other parts so so deputy
enforces spatial memory safety that is
it enforces that there aren't any out of
bounds memory accesses in a program so
it works by allowing the programmer to
add annotations on point
types so for example here you can add an
annotation on a function parameter which
is a pointer saying how many elements
are pointed to by buf and the argument
to the annotation n is another parameter
to the function and so deputy allows you
to write annotations like this any
pointer type in the program in in
structures or variables or function
brainers so then so deputy also allows
you to write annotations saying things
like this is a tagged Union this is a
null terminated array and also it has
some features for supporting
polymorphism so then deputy we'll take a
look at these annotations and it will
figure out what bounce checks need to be
added to enforce these types at at
pointer arithmetic and then we have a
subsequent phase that goes through and
looks to all of these assertions and if
it belongs succeed it takes it out if it
will always fail it's a compile time
error and so deputy the checks that it
does are sufficient to guarantee type
safety but only when the program is
single threaded and only when there
aren't any dangling references so that
brings us to keep safe so keep safe
enforces temporal memory safety by which
I mean it enforces that there aren't any
dangling references in a program and it
does this by way of reference counting
so we keep a one byte reference count
for every 16 bytes of memory and then on
when you call free on a pointer you you
just check that pointer is the last
reference to that that region of memory
so when you're doing reference counting
you always have this problem with cycles
so heap safe deals with this by adding a
couple of API calls begin delayed freeze
and end delayed freeze and so the way
this works is that after a begin delayed
free the runtime will keep a list of all
the pointers that you free and while you
do this it also goes through and it will
not allow
of the the fields and in the structure
and then at the end delay free call we
do all the checking to make sure that
you were really freeing the last
references and actually free the objects
then sew together deputy and heat-safe
can provide type safety and memory
safety but they're not sound for
multi-threaded code but that's sort of
the case where you'd actually like to
have a little extra help because the
multi-threaded programming is a little
bit more tricky
so this is where shark comes in so the
goal is to capture to both capture the
the the idioms that C programmers you'd
use try multi-threaded programs but also
to fix the sound of problems in deputy
in the heap safe so just to review
really quick you know the common
concurrency bugs so you can have data
races which happened when two threads
access the same location in memory and
one of them is right and there isn't any
intervening synchronization and this can
lead to lost updates and other
inconsistencies in state but you can
also have time of check versus time of
users for example the state of the
program could change after a deputy
check but before any subsequent pointer
arithmetic that he was checking for and
you can also have dead locks but I'm not
going to talk about deadlocks today so
concurrency bugs are a big problem if
you go and look in Bugzilla databases
and in major pieces of open source
software you can you can get the numbers
in particular as a February there were
62 outstanding known race conditions the
Linux kernel and 23 outstanding known
race conditions in Firefox and 30
outstanding known deadlocks and Linux
kernel and xxx over 46 known outstanding
deadlocks and Firefox and these are just
the known bugs so there's probably a
whole bunch more
so yeah today I'm gonna worry more about
data races than deadlocks but really
these are sort of closely related
problems you know you might add extra
locks to your program to get rid of a
data race but if you do that you might
introduce deadlock and then you can you
know then remove some locks but then you
might have another data race so these
are these are kind of closely related
problems where race freedom really isn't
sufficient so people have a strategy for
writing correct concurrent programs but
a race detector doesn't really know what
that strategy is it tries to infer what
is buggy behavior based on the the
access the memory access pattern in the
program so this could lead to both false
positives and false negatives so the
contribution of shark is that we want to
allow sharing of data among threads in a
program only when the programmer intense
and the way that charcoal has a
programmer to do this is by allowing him
to declare a high level sharing strategy
that is what is the sharing mode for a
particular object in a program and where
does the the sharing mode for an object
change as a program runs so shark will
then use a combination of sound static
and dynamic analysis to to make sure
that to enforce the sharing strategies
with programmers declared essentially
such that violations of the sharing
strategy include what what would
otherwise be the the real data races in
the program so we've also applied shark
to a bunch of real programs one of which
is about a million lines of code we also
we've also run it on a couple of
scientific codes with some interesting
data structures the the runtime overhead
on the the scientific codes is about 40%
but generally the runtime overhead is
under 20%
but could you use this as a bunny oh
yeah so you run it in it and employ a
overhead well I think it does as he said
depend on what the application is I
think for for scientific codes it
probably doesn't make a lot of sense it
probably does make more sense to use it
as a de bugging tool and so we have a
you know we have a modem shark that's
just log and continue so you can run the
program and it's slow but you see all of
the errors that you might have at the
end we also have a you know a stop on
air mode which probably makes more sense
when the runtime overhead is lower for
some you know less compute intensive
application
I think I could reduce the overhead so
at the moment a lot of the runtime
overhead for the scientific applications
comes from maintaining the reference
counts and so these use a concurrent
reference counting algorithm that
requires each thread to keep a log of
its updates and then when some thread
wants to know a particular reference
count it has to process the logs and
then also update reference counts in a
big global array off to the side so I
think there's definitely some work we
could do at making the reference
counting algorithm a little bit more
cache friendly among other things
right so I mentioned these sharing modes
so currently shark has these six sharing
notes so there's a private mode for
objects that are accessible only to a
single thread there there are there's a
read-only mode for objects that are read
by a thread but aren't writable there's
a lock sharing mode for objects that are
accessible by a thread owned by only the
thread that holds the lock there's a
dynamic mode and this tells shark to
check at run time that an object is
either private or read-only we have a
barrier sharing mode
it's like dynamic but the checking
resets at a barrier and there's a racing
mode for objects on which the programmer
knows that there are benign data races
so yeah so I think that would definitely
be a great addition to shark but we
don't it we don't currently up lament
any checking for that yeah I mean it
certainly is none of the benchmarks we
looked at use those sorts of operations
so the the sharing modes in shark are
our type qualifiers so we have this
declaration here in read-only star
private X so this is a a private pointer
to read on the integer so private here
means that the variable X can only be
accessed by the owning thread and the
read-only here means that the target of
X can only be read so we have a well
form in this rule for how these types
can be written in particular you can't
have an on private pointer to a private
object and so in the operations we're
going to do coming up here the the key
invariant is that all pointers to an
object have to agree on that object
sharing mode so I also mentioned on a
previous slide a sharing strategy so by
by sharing strategy
a combination of the sharing modes in
the program plus we're in the program
the sharing modes change so for example
you can have a lock protected counter or
a queue or a cache and you use the lock
sharing mode you can also have data
that's initialized privately tool one
thread and then shared with everybody
else in a read-only mode and then you
the object would start out in the
private mode and then switch to the
read-only mode you can also have objects
transferred among threads by way of
locks or signals and so an object could
start out private to one thread then be
put on some lock protected queue and
then be taken off the queue by some
other thread and then it would be
private to that thread you can also have
lock protected protected objects move
between different lock protected data
structures so an object might be in the
lock mode with one lock and then become
private to some thread and then go to
being in the lock mode for some other
lock so in in shark the mode changes are
expressed as type casts and I'll refer
to them as sharing casts my least-loved
so so I can see that data structures may
move you know from one thread to another
by a shared data structure like the
queue or something like
producer-consumer pattern so here you
say Lockleys o'clock so violence in the
data structure is protected by the log
of that list is this introducing that
could be yeah I mean it depends on the
program but I'm not sure how you would
catch it how would you capture that
producer-consumer example like yeah a
producer and he's privately to produce
it goes into a list or queues and then
consumer takes it out of the queue which
which one of these five interesting
so the the private to locked a private
one so I I hold I don't know some buffer
and then I write it with a sharing cast
into the field of some cue structure
that says it's protected by a lock and
then somebody wants to take it out of
the queue and so they'll do a sharing
cast from the long high of the queue
they're having along a low base
well I mean if that's how its
implemented them that's this is how you
would express them so now I'll give an
example of the initialisation case I
just mentioned so here we have a program
that has a global variable config and
it's a buffer that's going to be
read-only for all the threads and we
have a function called a knit in which
we allocate a buffer initialize it
privately to the thread and then write
the result into the global variable and
it start a bunch of threads that are
going to share so if we were to fully
annotate the program with sharks sharing
modes this is what it would look like so
the config pointer is a read-only
pointer to some read-only data and the
the local variable temp is a private
pointer to private data so there are a
couple problems right now
so first is that we're initializing a
global we're initializing read only
variable but this is ok because we can
initialize a read only variable while
the program is still single threaded the
other problem is that there's a type
error we're writing a private buffer
pointer into a read-only buffer pointer
so the way that shark deals with this is
by allowing the programmer to add an
explicit checked sharing cast so the
insight here is that if you have the
only pointer to an object then you're
allowed to change the sharing load of
the object
so what shark does is it uses heap safe
to maintain reference counts and it
checks that the reference count is 1 to
make sure that you will have the only
pointer at sharing cast when you do a
sharing cast shark also has to null out
the old pointer because it has the wrong
type so when we write something like
sharing cast of temp to read-only what
this actually means is that we're doing
the following things atomically
we have an assertion checking that the
reference count is one we do the
assignment from temp into config and
then we know out the old pointer because
it has the wrong type so I also want to
mention that shark can infer a lot of
these annotations and this inference is
based primarily on heuristics yeah but
I'm not sure that programs real always
just that one might say they should be
passed it is mature
perhaps not in the programs we've looked
at that's been the case in these
operations how's that expressed to the
programmer so I don't write innovation
at all and I read the hot stuff
I get out with that sense I've inserted
the plumbing sharp cast so shark won't
add casts automatically but it will
infer some annotations based on things
you've already written so this is mainly
for convenience rather than for
correctness and it's easy to override if
shark gets it wrong so in this case for
example so if the programmer writes read
only here on the right side of the star
shark will just say okay well the the
buffered point is probably also read
only and the programmer can override
that just by putting an explicit
annotation here and and similarly here
for temp it's a local variable so shark
infers that it's private and there's
nothing to suggest that it points to
anything other than private buffer so
that annotation also defaults to private
and again if it's wrong the perfect
programmer can override it with an
explicit annotation so one thing the
char can also do for on annotated
objects is we can do a thread escape
analysis so a shark will infer that an
object is in the night and I'm the
annotated object is in the dynamic mode
if a thread escape analysis says that
that object might escape and then
projects in the dynamic mode shark will
check that the object is either private
or read-only so let me explain for a
moment why that's needed
so here's another example in which we
have an global integer variable that's
only going to be touched by thread 4 and
so we have a function that's read done
by a whole bunch of threads and inside
of this function the thread for counter
will get incremented only by thread 4
and E is some expression that identifies
which thread is thread 4 so it might be
hard to tell statically that e is only
going to be true for thread 4 and if we
could tell them you know if we had a
strong enough static analysis we could
tell that that thread 4 count is private
so charcoal and for the dynamic mode for
that variable and and so the idea here
is that where the static analysis is
static analysis is hard the dynamic mode
allows us to do some checking to say
that ok well I don't know what it is
statically but maybe at runtime I can
check that it's you know private or
read-only so here's a good
right so we I'll talk about that in a
little bit so so far I've I've talked
about sharing modes and the sharing
caste and the dynamic mode and so what
I'm going to talk about next is a little
bit about how the sharing castes work
for a data structure with a bunch of
different objects in it and then I'll
talk about the guarantees that shark is
actually providing and then I'll talk
about the implementation that we did and
how we've evaluated the tool then I'll
wrap up and talk about some future
directions for IV so let's go back to
the initialization example but I'm gonna
change a little bit
instead of initializing some global
buffer I'm going to change it so that
it's initializing a sum some linked list
that's protected by a lock so we have a
list data structure and a mutex for
protecting the global list head geo and
then we have a function called init and
what an it does is that it allocates a
head of the list and passes the head of
the list to some other function which
initializes the list and returns us a
pointer to the tail the list or just
anywhere in the middle of the list and
then what the initialization function
will do is it will acquire the lock and
then what the programmer is trying to do
here is cast the whole list all at once
from private to locked and assign it to
the global list pointer but there's a
problem here so if shark so after the
call to an it list on the head of the
list this is what things look like so
the the globalist pointer might point
somewhere else it doesn't matter
Butthead now points to the beginning of
some list with a bunch of nodes in it
and tail points somewhere into the
middle of the list and so the the
intention of the programmer is to now
take the global list which is pointed to
a list in the lock mode and assign it to
the list that we've just initialized
privately to some thread
so if shark were to allow this there'd
be a problem there's a problem here so
we have tail still thinks the thing it's
pointing to is private which is a
problem because then we have one pointer
pointing to that node that thinks it's
locked and another pointer pointing to
that node that thinks it's private so
shark doesn't allow the sharing cast in
this case we have to do something else
yeah well it's also because I'm you know
when you step through this list you want
to know that each node is locked for
example so the next pointer of the node
that has nine thinks that the node that
has three is locked whereas the tail
pointer thinks that first yeah so I'm
watching over some details here in
particular we have some qualifier
polymorphism for structure types so if
you have a lock list than the qualifier
on the the head it gets transferred to
the qualifier the other point
so also when you cackling do this test
there you didn't have a temple in
earthen automatic valve and it's winners
also change
that's what we would like to happen and
so the goal now is to check that that
operation is actually safe
well we so this will fail if you wrote
this it will fit it would fail static
because you can't do a single object
sharing mode change on a structure type
that has pointers in it you have to do a
different thing yeah okay even if the
teleporter name didn't exist you
couldn't do it because of okay so the
way that we deal with this is with this
idea called groups so a group of a group
is a collection of objects in a C
program that are identified by a
distinguished group leader for example
the head of the list or the root of a
tree and so we add this annotation to
shark that allows the programmer to
identify external pointers into a group
of objects and these external pointers
have to depend on a pointer to the group
leader so we use a dependent type
annotation group group of G that means
this is a pointer into the group of
objects whose group leader is the target
of G so for example if we had our global
linked list on the previous slide and GL
is a pointer of the head of the list so
GL is a point of the group leader so GL
is also an external pointer into the
group so we would annotate the type of
GL by saying it's in group it's in the
group identified by itself GL and so we
also need to identify internal pointers
in a data structure and we do this with
this same annotation here so if if you
have a pointer in a data structure that
goes into the same group and you can
just write same so that so that char can
find the internal pointers in a group
we go back so external pointers then
if you're going to traverse it it means
that you have to have the same block
when you go in there the same block yes
right so if I'm coming in with this
external pointer then I better take the
law that is associated with the head of
the leader right before
so it's through fundraisers that the
little the dependency is a little bit
like ownership in object-oriented yeah
it's very similar but but here the ideas
the data structure has these things
coming from outside
maybe deep inside that seems to be a
little bit
I'm just trying to understand it with
respect
so we can do so yeah so if we were to
take the the program and write in our
group annotations it would look like
this so we have a same annotation on the
next pointer and the list data structure
we have a group annotation on external
pointers into the list in particular for
the global list pointer and for the
local pointers that we use in the
initialization function and then instead
of a sharing caste we're going to do a
group cast a G cast operation and the
idea here is that we want to use our
knowledge about the internal and
external pointers to make sure that this
operation is safe so what we can do and
I'm only going to talk about this very
briefly and I can I can talk with you
about it in detail offline if you're
interested is that we're going to do
some use dependent deputy style
dependent type checking of the group and
same pointers so in order to check the
do dependent type checking for the group
annotations deputy adds in some null
checks some null pointer checks and it
turns out that the the null pointer
checks the deputy adds in to do it's
dependent type checking are sufficient
to enforce the key invariant that all
pointers to an object agree all pointer
to an object agree on that objects
sharing them and to reduce the
annotation burden shark adds in or shark
has a sensible set of default
annotations for different situations and
also the the compiler can guide the
programmer to places where the the
default has to be overridden to get the
program of the Timeship
so now I'm going to talk about a little
bit about the guarantees that shark
actually provides so if there aren't any
compile time errors then shark
guarantees that private objects are only
accessed by that one thread that read
only objects are in written and that
sharing modes agree at assignments and
farg in passing that is just basic type
safety if there aren't any runtime error
errors then shark guarantees that there
aren't any data races on dynamic objects
in the dynamic mode or the barrier mode
that locked objects are always protected
by the lock the the right lock that and
they're not accessed unless the lock is
held and that no reference is with the
wrong type exist after a airing or a
group cast
shark özil guarantees that violations of
the sharing strategy include the data
races on a particular run of the program
except on objects that the program has
explicitly mark Tracy
also if there are if there's a data race
between two threads running in the
program then shark will generate
generate an error regardless of the
thread schedule and we also have a
soundness proof that shows that shark
actually provides these guarantees on a
simplified C like language that includes
the private locked and dynamic modes
with the group and sharing tests so now
I'll talk a little bit about the
implementation so at runtime we do race
detection for objects in the dynamic and
barium so the way we do this is by
keeping a big array off to the side and
tracking the number of readers or a
writer for every 16 byte chunk of memory
and we reset we reset this data as
appropriate when memory is allocated or
freed or when threads
I respond or die and we also do
efficient reference counting with heap
safe to check the sharing and group
castes and this is based on an efficient
reference counting efficient can
concurrent reference counting algorithm
so the the threat escape analysis I
mentioned before is is is actually
optional it's a it's an optimization it
would be safe to leave everything
annotated dynamic it would just be a bit
expensive so we do this threaded escape
analysis so that we can figure out that
a bunch of stuff in the program is
actually private thread thread private
and we can also do another optimization
that's very similar to we do a buffalo
insensitive type qualifier analysis to
restrict reference counting only to
those objects that might be involved in
a sharing caste or a group cast
so shark is implemented for see using
the SIL compiler front-end and about
5,500 lines of oh camel and it's
integrated into the IV compiler so now
I'll talk a little bit about how we've
evaluated shark so the goal here is more
to investigate the runtime and
programming overheads rather than to go
on a bug finding this mission and so
we've applied shark to a bunch of
different programs applications and yes
a couple of scientific codes and a
webserver and a couple of image
manipulation programs and including the
so before I give the results I want
to talk a little bit about how we
actually went about applying shark to
these programs the way we did was as
false so we we would compile the
programs with shark without making any
annotations and then and with the threat
escape analysis turned on so that
anything that might be touched by
multiple threads in the program gets
inferred to be in the
dynamic mother and then we we run the
program in in sharks log and continue
mode and we inspect the the error
messages that get generated is to to see
how the objects are shared in the
program and then based on the error
messages and based on you know some
hints from a program itself like
comments and variable names we can go
through and figure out what annotations
and sharing casts are needed in
different places and we repeat this
process until we don't get any more
err error messages um is this hard to
see yeah so these are the results and I
want to point out a few things first I
want to point out that we've actually
got this running on some big real
programs the second thing I want to
point out is that you you you don't
really have to make very many
annotations to get this idea to work so
the the density of the annotation goes
from being about four four hundred lines
of code to being about one for ten
thousand lines of code and the what we
found in terms of the the need for
writing a bunch of annotations is that
the the number of annotations you need
doesn't increase with program size it
increases with the complexity of the
concurrency and in the program so we
have a program like the where it's
you know exploiting some embarrassing
parallelism with regards to image
manipulation manipulation and so you
only need 70 annotations for a program
that's almost a million lines but for
smaller programs but which have some
more complex concurrency like the the
scientific benchmarks a Barnes and e/m
3d if smaller programs that need you
know about the same number of
annotations um finally I want to point
out the runtime overhead
which are fairly low if you compare with
or are competitive with existing raise
detectors so to to conclude the
incorrect sharing leads to data races
and deadlock and some other bugs but
with a few simple annotations on types
shark allows a programmer to specify
sharing mode for objects but also to
specify where in the program the sharing
modes for the objects change and then
shark will check that the program
actually adheres to the declared sharing
strategy with a combination of static
and dynamic analysis and we've tried
shark on a bunch of field programs and
observed some manageable slowdown and
memory overhead and we've released the
tool and it's available at this URL so
there's a bunch of related work in this
area there's a bunch of work on safe sea
dialects and race detection and
ownership type systems are kind of
related to our groups idea there's also
some shark inspired work there was a
Popple paper this year that takes a
fully dynamic approach and uses API
calls to change sharing modes there's
also a bunch of work here at Microsoft
which it probably makes more sense for
you to tell me about instead of the
other way around so now I'll talk a
little bit about some future directions
so one thing I've been thinking about is
using sort of IV like annotations and
analysis for annotating api's and
annotating for example you know if you
get an object from an API do you have to
free it do you have to acquire a release
a lock on it do you have to increment a
decrement a reference count on it also
I've been thinking about extending IV
features too
I love languages and this would require
increasing the support for polymorphism
both in IV in terms of type-checking but
also in terms of for example you might
need to add type qualifier arguments to
two templates or something like that
I've also been thinking about how to
make sharks analysis more static how to
reduce the dependence on dynamic
analysis both to reduce the overhead but
also to improve just the static
guarantees that we can make we also
thought about applying
shark-like techniques type annotation
and so forth for to guide performance
debugging of CUDA and OpenCL codes and I
mentioned these pessimistic atomic
sections at the at the very beginning of
the talk is one of the projects I'm
working on I think you could probably
apply these two languages like Nessie
that are used for embedded systems to
improve support for true multi-threading
and those in those sorts of languages
that's it questions
so no you mentioned that the table
earlier was part of our project knots
intended to fine folks but I'm sure you
must have figured out along the way
whether or not you actually
so there were there weren't we didn't
find any catastrophic bugs so we didn't
find any bugs that would cause a program
to crash we found we found bugs
databases that were things like you know
if there's a database in this case then
a loop will execute an extra time when
it didn't really have to and all it's
doing is waiting for something to happen
so there were things like that where you
know this this is this is really a
benign race that you were testing
through a shark was actually a
catastrophic bug free or that there's a
class of bugs that here
- so I think if we had done high
coverage testing of these programs you
probably would have found a bug or two
so our approach was mostly to you know
pick one or two inputs to the programs
and make sure that we were annotating
the program's to capture the concurrency
that was happening on for the for those
inputs and you know you can you can do
things like you know oh okay I've tried
this input and now there aren't any more
error messages and I've got the animate
the program annotated such that I think
it's correct so let's try another input
and then you sort of you know do that
until you're not seeing any more error
messages and you know that could lead
you to think that you have the the the
whole program annotated correctly but
you still might not actually be getting
very good coverage so for example for
the the is a huge program and
in our benchmark we were you know we're
not doing high coverage testing
essentially we're you know exercising
only some small part of the program in
the test but the annotations that we
have we think do correctly describe the
concurrency that would happen also in
other runs to be interesting to compare
the annotations with how much of that
you know for it that's linked
code that you actually covered I mean
you might have uncovered let's say a
thousand lines of code during the
runtime execution might be interesting
compared that to the an efficient you
know don't get a sense of an efficient
burnin as well as information about you
know how kind of human costly
innovations were that there's a missing
yeah I think that would be a good metric
but I I don't have those numbers
it was it was about a week
well so the so some of the annotations
one or two of the annotations were
tricky the thing that took a lot of time
with the in particular was that we
were doing this whole program analysis
this whole program thread escape
analysis so it would take a lot longer
than say GCC to compile though the whole
program
very like locations being
the way furthermore who'd use that as
wild programmers writing the application
or what
so the sense of how difficult for
your regular program it programmer it
would be you know editing the ambitions
of actually getting them right have you
tried any kind of research study no I
haven't done any user study but I would
really like to see how easy this is to
use for writing new code
semester that mr. Cruz
let it it'll see
you know why don't things like my single
so for Firefox in particular it's it's
written in C++ and our front-end only
handles see I mean also I don't know off
the top my head whether it's C or C++ I
think you know when we were doing this
validation we were we basically picked
one bigger program which was begin
so the one that you were starting with a
different language like C C sharp what
how would that affect the sort of here
their design decisions
so I'm not I'm not hugely familiar with
c-sharp but I'm guessing it's sort of
like Java so I think that definitely
you'd have to think about polymorphism
from the very beginning of the design
basically in the development of shark
for C the support from all mark
polymorphism is almost an afterthought
now or a convenience rather but
definitely for for Java or C sharp or
whatever you have to be thinking about
that from the very beginning and I'm not
I'm not sure exactly how that would
makes how I would make specific changes
the design is to support them is that
they're they're fairly restricted though
there's certain patterns that about data
structures that aren't both supported so
I'm wondering you know in your case are
there certain types of data structure
those things that you know what are the
limitations of your essentially
ownership type system if I can call it
that like things that you really can't
do that you'd like to be able to do
examples like hierarchical locking over
B trees I mean what sort of things can't
be do so I can't give a general
characterization of what sort of data
structures can and can't be handled but
for example something even as simple as
a linked list imposed on a hash table
for example for a you know an LRU cache
replacement policy for example I don't
think you can express with the group
annotations that we have you would want
something like membership in multiple
groups or something like that and I
haven't really thought that all the way
through
the data structures in these particular
applications but all amenable to
so everything that's fully annotated all
the all the recursive data structures
are only if they participate only if
they participated in the concurrent part
of the program